from last year on july 4th it was very
exciting because we all saved 16 cents
on our july 4th barbecue look at this
tweet from the white house planning a
cookout this year catch up on the news
according to the farm bureau
the cost of a fourth of july bbq is down
from last year it's a fact you must herd
hot dog the biden economic plan is
working and that's something we can all
relish
the cost of a fourth of july cookout in
2021 is down 16
cents for last year
uh from last year and then there was
this video this is a year ago i think
today peter ducey who is a rare
journalist that i can say there were
journalists without putting air quotes
he asked jen saki about these whopping
savings
okay on another subject the official
white house account tweeted yesterday
the cost of a fourth of july cookout is
down 16 cents from last year
16 cents there there has been a
reduction in some of the costs of key
components of the fourth of july fourth
of july barbecue that was what the tweet
was noting so does the white house think
that 16 cents off a barbecue has more of
an impact on people's lives than gas
being a dollar more this time
at this point i would say if you don't
like hot dogs you may not care of the
reduction of costs you don't have to
like hot dogs
i will say that what we are most focused
on is the fact that we've created now
more than three million jobs since the
president took office that's what we're
focused on and continuing to implement
additional uh components of his economic
build back better agenda
so i'm a big fan of showing these old
throwback videos because i think we
forget how inept these people are we
forget about all the people that got
here even watching sake just now i
forgot what she was like after you know
we have our new press secretary who you
have to say she's a black lesbian every
time you uh bring her up jean corrine
pierre uh 16 cents josh what'd you do
with your 16 cents before we get to this
year in the price increase what did you
do with your extra 16 cents last year
dave you know look i i mean maybe it
went just a little extra relish my
fourth of july hot dog or something but
i mean like you know to your point to me
i just had a flashback my mind literally
just now to that clip that went viral a
couple weeks ago of the new as you say
black lesbian press secretary at the
white house literally you remember this
when she was literally flipping through
the binder about the baby formula
shortage it was like literally like
nails on a chalkboard silence i mean
this administration just continues to
redefine incompetent each and every day
that ends in y which obviously is all
seven days of the week i mean it's
hitting a new low basically every week
and you know this stuff is just crazy
i'm not sure when they signed up kind of
jewish dad humor to be writing these
kind of white house tweets i mean
my my you know my 65 year old father
could have written that tweet but i'm
not sure it's very presidential
with the news people do you think that
there was literally one person last year
i mean i really mean this do you think
one person saw that tweet and said boy i
saved 16 cents thank you joe biden
i i don't think so and uh if you kind of
pull back it's really interesting and
basic communication strategy you always
want to lead uh with the best news that
you have the strongest uh kind of brag
about what you've been up to and
they looked at the whole white house
looked around at the country and said
all right this is what we go with today
this is the best news that we can
possibly come up with some sort of
artificial basket of goods like
rutabagas and something obscure where
they could say well the price is
actually down not up in comparison to
everything that you'd see at the store
if you would go today
but more seriously this administration's
kind of key playbook is to suppress
reality with these false images
so i think very similarly to this you
look at the uh the guy with the high
heels and the dress and the bald head
doing the kind of pup kinks
taking over the nuclear waste disposal
and you say well what is the substance
the substance is that our nuclear energy
program uh hasn't advanced in decades
but at least you get the bald pup kink
guy you know flexing his heels in the
white house photographs and so they're
trying to
kind of replace any substantive tangible
good for actual real-life people with
these fake images whatever they may be
uh day by day yeah that's a great point
because you know we're talking about
jean-claude pierre too and there was
that image of her a few weeks ago with
rachel levine and it's like they're
there and it's pride month and they're
very happy and we've got the first black
lesbian and the first trans whatever and
it's like well are you guys qualified at
your jobs is this pup person qualified
to be a nuclear i guess the pup guy does
have some pedigree if people don't know
about someone qualified yeah yeah he's
at least somewhat qualified i suppose
anyway uh all of this leads us to what's
happening this year in the world of
reality and yeah you're not
saving 16 cents anymore take a look
we're less than a week away from
america's birthday on the celebration
menu we get together with the family and
have a barbecue burgers and hot dogs
corn on the cob but choppers brace
yourselves because according to the
american farm bureau federation market
survey americans will be spending on
average around 70 dollars for a 10
person july 4th menu up 17 compared to
last year there's some shenanigans going
on economists explain the shenanigans as
inflation
we like showing
local news every now and again because
it's such a time warp isn't it i don't
have a tv anymore but when you see those
clips and they get the people outside
it's like there's something oddly
refreshing about it in our bizarro world
these days so spencer we went from
saving 16 cents very exciting to prices
going up 17
not 17 cents 17 percent will you be
splitting one hot dog
i'll be actually late for now yeah i'll
be carving it up into little slivers and
giving it out to the guests at my party
you